bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sauna pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
une séance que vous allez pouvoir suivre
sur notre antenne dans 15 minutes à 15
heures très précisément onze questions
vont être posées par les sénateurs pour
interpeller le gouvernement sur des
questions très large et des sujets très
large comme les assassinats encore ça
c'est une question du sénateur corse
nicolas alfonsi est également une
question sur la cyber défense de
jean-marie bockel ou encore luc
carvounas du groupe socialiste qui va
interpeller le gouvernement sur la
situation de l'emploi les très mauvais
chiffres du chômage annoncée hier et
puis également une question du sénateur
ump gérard larcher l'ancien président du
sénat sur l'organisation des travaux
parlementaires questions liées sans
doute à l'annulation hier par le conseil
constitutionnel de la loi sur le
logement annulation pour vice de forme
on peut dire alain vidalis bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau vous
être le ministre chargé des relations
avec le parlement et le moins qu'on
puisse dire cette semaine c'est que
c'est une tâche assez lourde
oui c'est une tâche assez lourde c'est
une tâche normale et quand il ya des
dysfonctionnements au parlement
naturellement le ministre des relations
avec le parlement est en première ligne
c'est normal alors le quotidien
libération titrait ce matin gouvernement
frag flagrant délit d'amateurisme
c'est vrai j'ai franchement je trouve ça
totalement exagéré je renvoie chacun
d'ailleurs à un article que j'ai
retrouvée et de 2007 et qui portent
exactement le même titre
à propos de l'ancienne majorité et de
l'ancien gouvernement et qui cite toute
une série d'exemples sur les difficultés
entre le parlement et le gouvernement et
je crois qu'un jour ou l'autre il faudra
qu'on sache qu'on veut si le modèle
politique auquel on aspire c'est la
corée du nord soit qu'ils n'ont pas de
problème avec le parlement mais quand il
ya un parlement quand il ya deux
chambres bien chacun doit pouvoir
s'exprimer c'est tout à fait normal
qu'il y
à un moment donné des positions
différentes
encore faut-il respecter les règles de
procédure parlementaire alain vidalis
tout à fait je pense que la décision du
conseil constitutionnel on en prend acte
il faut regarder un peu techniquement ce
qui s'est passé notamment ici ici au
sénat comment vous l'expliquez vous ab
d'une manière très simple je pense que
il y avait un calendrier qui avaient été
accélérés sur un sujet qui correspond
vraiment aux attentes des français le
logement social la conférence des
présidents du sénat avait choisi une
procédure un peu dérogatoire elle n'est
pas d'ailleurs annulé ni sanctionné
véritablement par le conseil
constitutionnel
c'est à dire que le texte de la
commission ne devait pas être adoptés et
on devait continuer le débat sur la base
du texte du gouvernement ce qui est
prévu or le texte de la commission quand
même été adoptée ici est ce qui fait que
la procédure n'était plus n'était plus
régulière c'est juste un détail de
procédure mais qui a des conséquences
importantes c'est vrai aujourd'hui
mais un sénat qui a quand même dû
travailler sur le texte vous le savez
une cadence très très très accéléré est
ce qu'on peut continuer à examiner comme
ça des textes en urgence en la procédure
d'urgence elle même n'est pas écartée
dans tous les cas parler de la procédure
d'urgence ensuite sur les délais
naturellement le gouvernement sera
extrêmement attentif à ce que les
assemblées et le sénat puisqu'on est ici
puissent avoir le temps de travail est
d'ailleurs c'est ma - avis une condition
pour faire du bon travail législatif en
même temps rappelez-vous les
circonstances de cette affaire au moment
où le président de la république décide
d'accélérer le calendrier les
commentateurs c'est plutôt du style mais
qu'est ce qu'ils font pour quoi ils
travaillent pas au gouvernement et aux
parlementaires aussi c'est pour ça qu'on
a un petit peu de mal à voir la
lisibilité de l'action gouvernementale
entre accélération et freinage on prend
son temps pour réfléchir
ben je pense qu'il ya une question de
méthode d'abord il ya des sujets sur
lesquels il est même question de tempo
politique quel gouvernement
il ya une question de méthode ce
gouvernement a choisi la conservation ça
a été fait sur le contrat de génération
c'est pas une méthode à brut on a saisi
les partenaires sociaux et peut-être que
l'un des événements importants au site
cette semaine pour la vie
les français c'est que dans ce pays
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
et patronales se sont mis d'accord pour
un texte qui va permettre le maintien
dans l'emploi des seniors et l' embauche
de jeunes c'est peut-être des éléments
les plus importants même si c'est un des
moyens commenté
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le terme
d'amateurisme qui revient non seulement
une de libération mais également une du
monde ce soir et de beaucoup de journaux
aujourd'hui est ce quand même une
semaine très noire pour le gouvernement
et pour un premier ministre qui a dû de
plus en plus de mal à s'imposer
oui ce dont je rappelais tout à l'heure
c'est un article du journal le monde de
2007 six mois après l'entrée en mls
six mois après c'était les couacs dans
la majorité les parlementaires ump qui
ont le blues
donc je crois que rien ne nous empêchera
de mener à bien les réformes que l'on
fait il ya eu un autre texte qui a été
guère examiné validée par le conseil
constitutionnel sur les emplois d'avenir
ce gouvernement travaille de parlement
légifère et la majorité du changement
est au rendez vous tout le reste je
crois n'est pas important pour les
français
donc vous dites que finalement c'est une
étape un petit peu normal quand il ya un
nouvel exécutif qui a été élu par les
français pas vous dire que c'est une
étape normale d'aboutir à une censure de
d'un texte par le conseil
constitutionnel c'est une erreur et je
l'assumé mais dans tous les cas la
question reste entière pour les français
celle du logement c'est un texte qui a
été combattue durement par la droite qui
s'initient au sénat et nous allons leur
présenter parce que les français ont
besoin de logement social et ses choix
je crois aujourd'hui ce que les français
attendent de la politique au début de
satin de cette interview je soulignais
la la lourdeur de voeux de votre charge
de la fonction de ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement notamment
ici au sénat où les choses sont vraiment
pas simple du fait de la courte majorité
de la gauche silva davance on le
rappelle je vous propose de regarder
tout de suite alain vidalis un sujet de
jérôme barbier autour justement de cette
difficulté de majorité au sénat et puis
on reprend le cours de notre interview
après la courte majorité au sénat va si
l approche du vote sur le projet de loi
de finances 2003
avec seulement six voix d'avancé pour la
gauche le ps aura besoin de tous ses
alliés radicaux verts mais aussi
communiste pourtant au moment de la
présentation du projet de budget en
septembre dernier pierre laurent affiche
et déjà son hostilité
qu'on ne nous dise pas que ce budget est
pargne neuf salariés sur 10 parce que
d'une part le gel du barème de l'impôt
sur le revenu va toucher un très grand
nombre de salariés et pas seulement
parmi les plus aisés le groupe
communiste entretient le suspense
jusqu'à mardi prochain pour savoir
quelle position adopter chez les verts
qui n'ont pourtant pas voter le récent
traité budgétaire européen
on appelle à plus d'unité il faut le
dire et je crois que c'est aussi valable
pour renault écologistes il faut être
capable au sirop moment important de
faire des efforts de quoi ils ont la
majorité
chaque allié à ses exigences dernier
exemple avec le texte sur le logement le
gouvernement a dû se plier aux demandes
des radicaux de gauche pour qu'il soit
adopté une indépendance revendiquée par
le groupe
nous nous avons l'habitude de dire ce
que nous pensons très clairement nous
avons aussi l'habitude d'être loyaux par
rapport à nos alliés mais nous n'avons
pas à faire un marchandage quelconque
avec le gouvernement ou avec tel ou tel
autre groupe ce n'est pas notre
tradition des tractations qui sont
pourtant quotidienne au sénat entre le
ps et ses alliés
le risque étant que lassé par cette
courte majorité le gouvernement finisse
par ne compter que sur sa majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale pour
faire adopter ses textes
effectivement alain vidalies s'il ya un
risque pour ces groupes de la majorité
qui sont parfois un petit peu turbulent
ici au sénat et bien que le gouvernement
finalement passé un peu au-dessus du
sauna pour
surtout s'appuyer sur l'assemblée
nationale c'est pas du tout du tout
l'opinion du gouvernement le
gouvernement sait qu'ici il ya une
majorité qui à sa réalité politique
cette réalité elle est c'est vrai un peu
complexe mais ça veut dire que le mot
d'ordre sur votre talent de négociateur
les radicaux les verts le front de
gauche ici au sénat mais surtout c'est
lé mode horde ses respects pédagogie et
dialogue avec tous les groupes et qui
constituent la majorité ici au sénat et
nous faisons et nous allons le faire
chacun a sa place dans cette majorité
si on prend effectivement les textes si
on détaille un parent texte ou ceux qui
vont venir devant le sénat par exemple
sur la loi de finances est ce que vous
avez peur ici que le front de gauche ne
suivent pas le gouvernement
c'est une question qui est posée à la
fois au front de gauche est à la fois à
l'institution un peu au parlement
puisque chacun sait que si la première
partie de la loi de finances n'est pas
voté le sénat ne pourra pas examiné
l'émission c'est à dire le détail delà
de l'action des services publics en
france ce qui ce qui poserait évidemment
une grande difficulté donc aujourd'hui
notre option c'est de poursuivre les
négociations
répondre expliqué et je crois que quand
on regarde l'une des mesures phares de
ce projet de loi de finances qui est
l'alignement des revenus du capital sur
les revenus du travail en matière de
fiscalité il me semble que c'est une
revendication très anciennes notamment
du front de gauche et qu'il pourrait se
retrouver dans cette démarche même si
nous sommes évidemment ouvert à
poursuivre le dialogue jusqu'au moment
où le texte sera ici en discussion
puisque vous parlez de la fiscalité
justement la droite envisage de faire un
recours pour non respect de l'égalité
devant l'impôt est ce que là aussi il ya
un risque d'inconstitutionnalité sur le
projet de loi de finances 2013
je vais pas reprocher à la droite
d'exercer son devoir d'opposition nous
l'avons fait en notre temps je n'ai pas
mais je n'ai pas mesuré mais le
naturellement c'est son rôle de saisir
le conseil constitutionnel
il ne me semble pas et je ne vois pas
sur quoi pourrait reposer aujourd'hui
une question d' inégalité devant l'impôt
mais c'est vrai que de ce point de vue
là on a affaire à des experts quand on
sait ce qu'ils avaient fait sur l'impôt
sur la forêt mais christian eckert le
rapporteur général du budget à
l'assemblée nationale
m a parlé hier d'une fiscalité quasi
confiscatoire or il n'a pas parlé d'une
fiscalité ghazi cas si confiscatoire
crois pas qu'il ait fait de
démonstration sur ce point je crois
qu'aujourd'hui lorsque on demande à ceux
qui bénéficiaient des avantages de
l'ancienne majorité finalement un
traitement de droit commun c'est quoi la
fiscalité c'est de payer un impôt
progressif en fonction de ces mots de
ses moyens c'est la réponse juste à une
situation que nous avons trouvé c'est
pas nous qui avons pour l'instant on
était la france c'est une situation qui
a été fait pendant cinq ans et quand
même 600 milliards de plus il faut
aujourd'hui que la france rembourse
comment la france va rembourser par
s'endettant encore elle va rembourser
avec un effort des français et c'est
toute la question de l'effort du
redressement devant la justice et quelle
concession vous pourriez trouver avec le
front de gauche pour les amener vraiment
à voter ce premier volet la loi de
finances écoutez on va alors on les a
rencontrés on les écoute on va les
rencontrer et il faut ils sont sensibles
à quel sujet par exemple
d'après ce que j'ai compris à la
question de la fiscalité sur sur le
barème de l'impôt sur le revenu sur le
maintien de son gel décidé par l'ancien
gouvernement
il faut aussi expliquer très précisément
ce qu'il ya c'est à dire que les
salariés petits et moyens ne sont pas
touchés puisque on a neutralisé ses
effets pour ses salariés
est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin je
pense que le dialogue est ouvert dans
tous les cas on va les écouter aussi
bien expliquer ce que l'on a fait parce
qu'il ya eu rarement du point de vue
fiscal et je sais que c'est pour eux
c'est important
une loi fiscale qui soit avec des
marqueurs de gauche aussi fort autre
texte qui pourrait être rejeté par le
sénat
c'est la proposition de loi sur une
transition énergétique sobre un texte
sur l'électricité de françois brottes ya
pas eu de majorité en commission en tout
cas si une majorité justement pour voter
une motion d'irrecevabilité
ce qui fait que le texte a été rejeté en
commission ça ne va certainement pas non
plus passer en séance
je ne sais pas ce qui va se passer en
séance mais dans tous les cas l'objectif
personnel pour que ça passe non alain
vidalis il ya peu de chance mais
l'objectif est partagée sur les ce qu'on
appelle la tarification progressive de
l'énergie c'était un engagement du
président de la république et c'est à la
majorité de le tenir
il ya des discussions sur le contenu
technique il ya une appréciation
différente mais comme il ya un objectif
partagé
nous allons poursuivre la procédure la
commission mixte paritaire sera réunie
et j'espère que nous parviendrons à une
position qui sera qui sera commune
puisse mais ça sera sans doute la
version de l'assemblée nationale qui va
prédominer alors c'est toi s'est pas
arrêtée pour l'instant et moi je ne met
pas de côté ce qui a été la position du
sénat qui malgré cette motion
d'irrecevabilité reste dans le débat il
ya eu un travail important sérieux fait
ici au sénat et on doit le prendre en
considération quelle que soit la
décision finale et là aussi il ya
peut-être un risque
d'inconstitutionnalité pour rupture
d'égalité devant le tarif de
l'électricité est décidément il ya
beaucoup de gens mais vous savez
pratiquement sous tous les textes et sur
toutes les majorités sont déférés au
conseil constitutionnel c'est pas parce
qu'ils sont défaits il y avait forcément
des points d'inconstitutionnalité qui
sont soulevées sur tous les textes ben
écoutez je pense qu'on a pourrait mieux
fait plus vite de compter ceux sur
lesquels n'y a pas de recours que ceux
sur lesquels il y en a pour avoir été
longtemps dans l'opposition je peux vous
dire que quasi systématiquement des
recours sont effectuées et c'est tout à
fait logique et normal ils sont plus ou
moins fondées sur la rupture délégué
d'égalité franchement partir du moment
où il s'agit de protéger ceux pour qui
aujourd'hui c'est une charge trop lourde
je ne vois pas sur quels principes le
conseil consitutionnel viendrait
intervenir on est presque on est un peu
plus d'un an maintenant de la victoire
de la gauche au sénat et on se rende
compte que cette majorité de gauche
elle est vraiment très difficile à tenir
elle existe il ya un président il ya des
gaules existe belle et fragile elle est
fragile c'est une réalité et c'est une
réalité politique c'est le résultat du
choix des grands électeurs je sais que
le président du sénat s'emploie à la
faire vivre et le gouvernement
le désert se désespère pas du tout du
sénat ne considère pas que encore
coréens n'ont pas du tout et c'est pas
notre intention parce que pour faire de
bonnes lois il nous faut deux chambres
et puisqu'on a la chance ici de pouvoir
avoir démis une majorité alors nous
comptons sur le travail du sénat aussi
merci beaucoup alain vidalis d'avoir été
notre invité on l'a vu sur nos images le
président du sénat jean-pierre bel vient
de rejoindre l'hémicycle donc je vous
laisse à votre tour rejoindre
l'hémicycle pour aller sur les bancs du
gouvernement
et effectivement on vous allez pouvoir
suivre dans quelques instants en direct
sur notre antenne cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
elle va commencer par une question du
sénateur de corse nicolas alfonsi autour
d assassinat en corse c'est normalement
manuel valls le ministre l'intérieur qui
devrait lui réponde puis ensuite c'est
gérard larcher l'ancien président ump du
sénat qui va interpeller le gouvernement
et alain vidalies ce qui était à
l'instant sur notre plateau sur
l'organisation des travaux
parlementaires suite évidemment à
l'annulation par le conseil
constitutionnel de la loi sur le
logement
et puis après on aura différents thèmes
abordés par les sénateurs autour de
l'emploi
évidemment de la cyber défense mais
également de lambeaux guillot avec les
écologistes autour de l'aéroport de
notre dame de nantes nantes ou triste je
vous laisse rejoindre l'hémicycle du
sénat pour suivre en direct cette séance
est tout à la mairie ou la ministre pour
sa réponse dispose de deux minutes
trente pour la première question la
parole est à monsieur nicolas alfonsi
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
treize ans après l'assassinât du préfet
erignac la corse vient de vivre une
situation sinon comparable et traversent
une nouvelle crise le gouvernement à ce
lundi pris dix décisions qu'on mettre un
terme à une comptabilité mortifère qui
s'est poursuivie par un nouveau meurtre
hier matin pour avoir dit non au statut
joxe non accords de matignon non au
référendum de sarkozy y avoir toujours
privilégier le réinvestissement total de
l'état dans l'île jeu
les approuver au demeurant il se révèle
imputé à l'état seul la responsabilité
de la situation actuelle
certes il a connu des défaillances
quelle meilleure illustration de la mise
en sommeil du pôle financier queue de
classement sans suite en précisant
d'instruction par le parquet général de
bastia financier d'une banque régionale
merci défaillance ne saurait faire
oublier celle de la société corse des
connivences les solidarités qui la mine
et dont les premières victimes sont les
corses eux mêmes ainsi l'assemblée de
corse a refusé d'examiner une motion
condamnant un crime mafieux revendiqué
par le flnc au motif que les élus
nationalistes et les plus durs s'y
opposer
vaclav havel devenu président de la
république s'adressant à ses concitoyens
déclaré nous sommes malades moralement
parce que nous sommes habitués à dire
blanc et à penser noir ce jugement
pourrait s'appliquer à bien des
comportements locaux l'état ne doit dès
lors compter que sur lui-même sans doute
conviendrait-il de renforcer les moyens
de renouvellement mesures de politique
pénale pour la police qui est une action
toujours difficile à recréer car nous
savons tous qu'un océan existe dans les
affaires judiciaires entre le simple
soupçon et l'établissement de la preuve
que contrairement à la sourde raconte
sûreté de l'étang va agir c'est de
marseille
un jour c'est d'ailleurs comme l'a
déclaré le procureur d'alès tu ne
souhaitait être des juridictions
d'exception
aussi seuls les temps par une
communication efficace
rendant coup pour coup par une action
s'inscrivant dans la durée la continuité
par une volonté toujours réaffirmée pour
remettre la corse en possession d'
elle-même mais alors qu'aucune demande
n'existe dans l'opinion préoccuper plus
préoccupés par la crise économique et
sociale que par de nouvelles réformes
institutionnelles
le conseil exécutif et l'assemblée de
corse vont délibérer pour réclamer un
nouveau statut plus de compétences
toujours plus d'un
argent voire même une réforme de la
constitution craignons que ces nouvelles
réformes nous conduisent un terme à
l'effacement de l'état et laisse la
corse livrée à elle-même et à ses démons
le gouvernement ne pouvant conduire
monsieur le ministre de politique à la
fois merci de nous dire quelle est votre
priorité
merci mon cher collègue pour vous
répondre que ce manuel valls ministre
d'intérieur sur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur nicolas alfonsi la
corse c'est la france et c'est la
république et la france doit évidemment
soutien et protection à la corse et aux
corses et c'est évidemment sens de
l'engagement économique de l'état à
travers le plan d'investissement
exceptionnel et l'etat sera présent
auprès des collectivités dans ce sens
mais aujourd'hui vous avez eu raison de
le souligner la corse connaît de nouveau
est-ce que cela s'est vraiment arrêter
une vague de violences une vague de
violence qui remonte à loin et qui
gangrènent profondément la société corse
l'état doit tout simplement assumer vous
l'avez dit ses responsabilités en
profondeur et dans la continuité et
c'est le sens des mesures qui ont été
annoncées par le premier ministre lundi
dernier avec christiane taubira la garde
des sceaux
pierre moscovici ministre de l'économie
jérôme cahuzac ministre du budget et moi
même pour montrer la détermination de
l'état sa volonté de s'attaquer en
profondeur à ces mafias au crime
organisé à l'argent détourné au
financement occulte et pour cela nous
avons besoin d'une action en profondeur
en soutenant davantage le travail
interministériel la coopération entre
les services de police et de gendarmerie
et la coopération entre la police et la
justice
et christiane taubira déjà annoncé que
de nouvelles mesures de politiques
pénales seront proposés et nous nous
rendrons dans les prochaines semaines
avec la garde des sceaux pour affirmer
la volonté intraitable de l'état
républicain assumer ses responsabilités
mais nous avons besoin de deux choses
nous avons besoin du soutien des élus et
de la société corse
à chacun de prendre ses responsabilités
l'état prendra ses responsabilités mais
il est temps aussi que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités pour lutter contre les
crimes contre la délinquance il n'y a
pas une culture corse particulière il
n'y a pas la loi de l'omerta ça n'existe
pas ça en république monsieur le
sénateur et vous le savez bien et votre
combat courageux est là pour le
démontrer dont nous avons besoin de la
mobilisation de toute la société corse
et puis pour être aussi claire vis-à-vis
de votre question monsieur le sénateur
il n'y a pas de compromission possible
on peut pas mélanger des revendications
identitaires ou d'autonomie ou
d'évolution du statut alors que
précisément il y à de la violence je
vous le disais la corse c'est la
république la loi elle doit s'appliquer
pour lutter contre la délinquance et
pour lutter contre les crimes
il n'ya pas d'autre voie possible
merci la parole est à monsieur le
président jean marché pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je regrette l'absence du
premier ministre car c'est à lui que
s'adressait ma question
le conseil constitutionnel a annulé hier
soir la loi relative au logement que
vous avez présenté début septembre
ce n'est pas à quoi comme j'ai pu
l'entendre c'est à camoufler le
gouvernement a violé la constitution en
refusant d'appliquer correctement les
principes de la procédure législative
il a ignoré les droits du parlement
mieux encore le premier ministre a porté
atteinte à l'indépendance du conseil
constitutionnel en annonçant le matin
une décision qui n'était pas rendue le
premier ministre a prétendu je le cite
qu'il s'agissait d'un cafouillage
parlementaire non monsieur le premier
ministre je ne crois pas qu'il y ait eu
de cafouillage parlementaire c'est bel
et bien un cafouillage du gouvernement
non du sénat et encore moins de la
commission des affaires économiques j'ai
pu relire avec beaucoup d'attention les
travaux de la commission
faut-il rappeler les raisons pour
lesquelles le conseil constitutionnel a
fait droit à notre recours
vous avez fait pression sur le sénat
pour que nous délibérerons en séance
publique sur le texte du gouvernement et
non sur le texte modifié par la
commission
et c'est pourtant depuis 2008 une
obligation constitutionnelle mais en
fait vous n'en êtes pas votre coup
d'essai vous n'avez pas respecté la
constitution début juillet en refusant
d'organiser une séance de questions
d'ailleurs le conseil constitutionnel
vous a alors sèchement rappelés à
l'ordre
depuis l'élection du président de la
république françois hollande 100% des
sectes textes législatifs sont examiné
selon la procédure accélérée pas une loi
ordinaire n'a été examinée normalement
ou contourner les délais pour feindre
l'action je me tends d'un président du
sénat pour lui rappeler qu'il y a deux
ans trois ans quatre ans il était très
attentif sur cette question de la
procédure accélérée
auprès du président du sénat que j'étais
alors en fait la décision du conseil
constitutionnel
marca tournant elle consacre le
renforcement du rôle du parlement que
nicolas sarkozy et françois fillon ont
voulu en 2008 alors m'adressant aux
ministres en charge des relations avec
le parlement faute de premier ministre
ma question est simple allez vous enfin
respecter le parlement
allez vous enfin respecter l'opposition
et la séance d'hier sur le dossier des
normes ne m'a pas éclairé répondu allez
vous enfin respecter la constitution
mais j'ajoute un ma question une demande
quand vous allez soumettre le texte sur
le logement social au parlement je vous
demande solennellement d'utiliser la
procédure normale
c'est un sujet essentiel pour nombre de
français parmi les plus modestes
c'est un sujet essentiel pour nos
collectivités locales et il mérite un
vrai débat donc deux lectures dans
chacune de nos assemblées
monsieur alain vidalis ministre chargé
des relations avec le parlement
ah si merci monsieur le président
monsieur le monsieur le président
larcher
vous ressentez comme un camouflet pour
le gouvernement la décision qui a été
rendue hier par le conseil
constitutionnel dans sa grande sagesse
ça vous a pas échappé c'est assez rare
le conseil constitutionnel a précisé
dans le temps le
dans le communiqué dans le communiqué le
conseil constitutionnel a précisé qu' il
avait déjà été amenée pour des raisons
de procédure a annulé des lois pour non
respect de la procédure et notamment
dans une décision du conseil
constitutionnel du mois de juin 2011 qui
étaient très graves sur le président
puisque la loi sur le conseiller
territorial avait été annulée parce que
le gouvernement que vous souteniez la
majorité qui s'est exprimée ici encore
avait ignoré les droits du sénat je
pense qu'à l'époque vous avez dû
ressentir ça comme un super camoufler
donc quand il ya des erreurs il faut
aussi rappeler le conseil
constitutionnel la paix ce que vous
aviez la décision du conseil
constitutionnel dit y est je crois que
vous êtes suffisamment bon juriste pour
que on rappelle ce qui s'est passé et il
ya un mot dans votre question il n'est
pas juste monsieur le président larcher
vous ne pouvez pas dire ici sauf à
expliquer comment que le gouvernement
avait fait pression sur le sénat pour
que le débat s'ouvre sur le texte du
gouvernement
il n'y a eu et 7 la réalité tous les
documents sont annexés à la décision
il ya eu une décision de votre
conférence des présidents qui a été
prise d'utiliser l'exception de
l'article 92 et il avait raison et nous
avons accepté cette décision
elle était d'ailleurs contesté dans la
motion d'irrecevabilité
mais les juristes pourront observer que
ce débat n'est pas complètement vidés
par la décision du conseil
constitutionnel
jusqu en réalité
le président le président du sénat a
écrit aussi au conseil constitutionnel
pour défendre cette position qui était
la nôtre et elle était juste
malheureusement le conseil a dit mais
vous ne pouviez pas à la fois laissez
votre commission délibéré et en même
temps soumettre le texte au voile à
l'origine de la décision elle et elle
est normal puisque la procédure c'est le
conseil constitutionnel qui la contrôle
alors la situation d'aujourd'hui ne
peuvent pas quand même vous faire
oublier le fond du débat
vous l'avez rappelé nous vous même vous
avez rappelé que vous étiez très attaché
à la question du logement social
moi je veux simplement vous rappeler que
votre attachement vous l'avez jusqu'à
présente cette majorité l'a marqué dans
le combat contre les mesures pour la
création du logement social contre la
mobilisation du foncier public contre
les obligations pour les premiers
notamment les communes peuvent vous
dépendez comme neuilly de faire du
logement social
c'est ça la question qui intéresse les
français c'est pour ça que nous avons
été élus et au delà les incidents de
procédure
nous allons le faire
merci monsieur jean marie bockel pour le
groupe union des démocrates et
indépendants us et l'union sont si
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
kader arif mes chers collègues il ya eu
en france comme ailleurs depuis quelques
années un certain nombre de cyber
attaques tout à fait dévastatrice on en
a peu parlé mais il ya eu cette attaque
contre le ministère de l'économie des
finances l'an dernier à la veille du g8
g20
il ya eu une attaque contre le géant du
nucléaire français areva
sûrement de longue durée avec un pillage
très important de sa richesse mais il ya
eu également des attaques contre la
présidence de la république contre les
ministères pour ne citer que quelques
exemples qui concerne au fond les
intérêts vitaux de notre pays et puis si
on s'interrogeait sur la meilleure
manière de perturber gravement le
fonctionnement d'un pays comme le nôtre
par exemple paralysé par des cyber
attaques sur les systèmes informatiques
et internet
et bien tout simplement le transport
aérien ferroviaire le fonctionnement de
nos hôpitaux nos réseaux d'eau d'énergie
et bien dites vous bien que ce serait au
fond avec un minimum d'organisation
assez faciles à faire d'ailleurs si je
prends simplement comme exemple comme
exemple quelques attaques récentes qui
ont été destructrice je pense par
exemple au virus stuxnet qui a cassé
littéralement 1000 centrifugeuses à la
centrale de natanz duclair donc en iran
je pense très récemment encore à saudi
aramco le géant pétrolier qui a eu
trente mille ordinateurs détruits et
dont vous voyez que nous sommes là sur
des sujets qui ne relèvent pas du
fantasme et puis les intérêts vitaux
monsieur ministre s'est aussi nos
intérêts économiques car l'essentiel
aujourd'hui de ses pénétrations des
réseaux c'est de l'espionnage massif de
notre richesse industrielle est en
guerre économique ça compte
alors nous avons à la commission de la
défense et des affaires étrangères
adopté à l'unanimité un certain nombre
de pistes de propositions qui ont bien
sûr été soumise au gouvernement
et je crois que
nous attendons maintenant un certain
nombre de réponses parce que par rapport
à nos voisins je prends simplement des
oiseaux comme les britanniques et les
allemands de niveau comparable avec des
enjeux à la fois de sécurité économique
comparable
nous avons du retard par exemple
l'agencé nationale de sécurité des
systèmes d'information l'anssi qui a été
créé en 2009 qui est reconnue tant au
niveau national qu'international pour sa
compétence qui est aux côtés des
entreprises et des administrations qui
sont attaqués a besoin de voir ses
moyens à bon d augmenter on attend une
réponse
on attend également une réponse en
termes de sensibilisation du monde
économique des administrations signaler
les attaques afin qu'on puisse aider
vous le comprenez bien c'est un enjeu à
la fois de sécurité de vie quotidienne
de nos concitoyens un enjeu économique
nous attendons également à l'instar de
la grande bretagne d'autres pays voisins
de l'allemagne une prise en compte ou
plus haut niveau de l'état de cette
réalité des priorités et des réponses
que nous attendons à présent du
gouvernement merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur kader arif ministre
chargé des anciens combattants
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs sénateurs et sénatrices
monsieur le sénateur jean marie bockel
je n'ai d'abord à vous faire part des
excuses de jean yves le drian mise la
défense qui ne pouvait pas être parmi
nous aujourd'hui et vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir l'importance qu'accorde le
ministre de la défense à cette question
et qu'il a manifestée en se rendant à
brûler à côté de rennes pour visiter le
centre technique lui a déjà il y à peu
la cyberdéfense est constitué de
l'ensemble des moyens techniques et
opérationnelles
visant à détecter analyser réagir aux
attaques de nature informatique la
nature des systèmes vise est extrêmement
varié depuis les réseaux informatiques
classiques jusqu'aux systèmes d'armes en
passant par les systèmes industriels
l'objectif de ces attaques ou l'avait
rappelé peut être la recherche de
renseignements
la neutralisation des systèmes ou encore
la modification de l'information
l'organisation de l'état repose sur une
étroite collaboration entre l'agencé
nationale de sécurité des systèmes
d'information lancy j'y reviendrai et le
ministère de la défense
la coordination technique opérationnel
et crucial s'est traduit pour le mystère
la défense à une collaboration très
étroite entre la direction générale de
l'armement l'a déjà et lanta et l'état
major des armées
nous renforçons actuellement la
protection et la défense des systèmes
d'information la mue montée en puissance
de l'un ci se traduira par la création
de 65 postes supplémentaires en 2013 et
elle se poursuivra ensuite
le prochain livre blanc sur la défense
et la sécurité nationale devrait
réserver une attention particulière à
ces questions et plus particulièrement
au mr la défense et novices et général à
la cyber défense a été désigné une
structure spécifique le centre d'analysé
lutte informatique défensive le khalid a
été mis en place
le call it va passer de 20 à 40
personnes en 2013 pour être opérationnel
24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7
en outre un schéma directeur la
cybersécurité la cybersécurité a été
préparé il vise un renforcement
important du domaine nous avons ensuite
nommé un fonctionnaire la sécurité des
systèmes d'information il est rattaché
fonctionnellement en chef du cabinet
militaire du midd la défense ce qui est
une garantie de la prise en compte au
bon niveau de la question de la sécurité
dans le système d'information
enfin la dg a particulièrement son
centre technique de bruges ramphort
cette expertise technique déterminante
pour la souveraineté de la france par le
cru du recrutement planifié de 200
personnes dans les trois années
à venir j'espère avoir reconnu monsieur
les sénateurs à vos interrogations
merci la parole est à monsieur luc
carvounas pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés merci monsieur le président
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre du travail de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
et du dialogue social depuis 16 mois
consécutif les annonces de licenciements
et les plans sociaux se succèdent et
malheureusement les chiffres du chômage
augmente inexorablement la barre des 3
millions de chômeurs est aujourd'hui
dépassé nous savions tous que la
situation de notre pays était grave et
nous n'avions pas à sous-estimer les
résultats catastrophiques de la
politique menée par la droite pendant
dix ans ne vous énervez pas mes
collègues dès sa formation
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement a
mis en place une stratégie globale de
bataille pour l'emploi et agit sur tous
les fronts le gouvernement agit d'abord
sur les urgences
le ministre du redressement productif et
le ministre de l'agriculture pour la
filière agroalimentaire ont suivi au cas
par cas les entreprises en difficulté ou
en procédure de licenciement collectif
un accompagnement et des réponses lors
ont été apportées le gouvernement agit
aussi sur le court et moyen terme en
maintenant et en augmentant les contrats
aidés que l'ancienne majorité voulait
supprimer
vous l'avez fait également en créant
cent cinquante mille emplois d'avenir
pour les jeunes quittent le système
scolaire sans formation
le gouvernement agit enfin sur le long
terme par des mesures en faveur de
l'éducation clé de la réussite
aujourd'hui l'accord des partenaires
sociaux va permettre la mise en oeuvre
d'un engagement essentiel du président
de la république
les contrats de génération ils
permettront aux jeunes d'accéder à un
premier emploi et aux seniors trop
souvent écarté prématurément du monde du
travail de conserver leur tout en
transmettant leur savoir faire et leur
expérience
ces contrats sont le troisième volet de
la politique qui doit permettre
d'inverser la courbe du chômage
alors ma question est la suivante
monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous dire plus en détails
ce qu'il en est sur 6 10
son dispositif et le calendrier de leur
mise en oeuvre je remercie mes chers
collègues merci pour vous répondre
monsieur thierry repentin ministre
chargée de la formation professionnelle
et de l'apprentissage
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs et sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur carvounas vous me
permettrez de répondre en lieu et place
de michel sapin retenu aujourd'hui par
le forum des ministres du travail et de
l'emploi
vous l'avez justement dit la bataille de
l'emploi c'est la priorité du
gouvernement car nous considérons que la
situation économique et sociale l'église
l'exigent nous ne pouvons considérer
comme inéluctable la situation que nous
avons trouvé avec plus de 10% de la
population active au chômage plus de 3
millions de chômeurs car c'est ça la
réalité que nous avons trouvé en juin
dernier et également des plans sociaux
qui ont été habilement retardé et qui
viendront dans les mois encore augmenter
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi hélas
dans notre pays nous en riront monsieur
le sénateur cette spirale de l'échec et
fin 2013
nous nous ferons d'une telle façon que
la courbe du chômage puisse être
inversée
telle est la feuille de route qui était
indiquée par le président de la
république une feuille de route qui fait
écho sa double priorité emploi jeunesse
pour que les générations qui entre dans
le monde du travail les nouvelles
générations ne le fasse pas au détriment
de celles qui les ont précédées
la première traduction vous l'avez dit
de cette priorité elle est sur les rails
ce sont les 150 mille emplois d'avenir
monsieur le sénateur emplois d'avenir
validé hier par le conseil
constitutionnel car vous oubliez de dire
que vous avez essayé de faire censurer
cette disposition qui a été fait par la
nouvelle majorité au bénéfice de la
jeunesse de france ses premiers emplois
d'avenir seront signés dès le début du
mois de novembre prochain
partout dans tous les territoires de
france pour apporter une réponse aux
jeunes qui sont sortis du système
scolaire sans formation ce sera ainsi un
emploi une formation deuxième étape ce
sera les contrats de génération 500
milles qui vous seront proposées à
l'occasion d'un texte qui sera débattu
au parlement
en janvier prochain car sur le fruit
d'un travail négociée du dialogue social
renouvelé avec les partenaires sociaux
nous sommes tombés vendredi d'accords
avec les partenaires sociaux pour
présenter à la représentation nationale
ce texte qui alliera les anciens les
seniors et les juniors par un contrat
qui liera finalement deux générations
par un trans transmission de savoir et
enfin sans tarder dès la semaine
dernière 40 mille emplois aidés
supplémentaires ont été dévolus aux
préfets de vos départements respectifs
pour accompagner celles et ceux qui sont
durablement éloignés de l'emploi vous le
voyez nous agissons d'une façon concrète
respectant en cela les engagements du
président de la république pris pendant
la campagne bases sur lesquelles la
france a voulu une nouvelle majorité
merci la parole est à madame de corinne
bouchoux pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs chers collègues
ma question concerne une problématique
de transport mais qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences beaucoup plus importante et
je voudrais rappeler que la solidarité
n'exclut pas la franchise la solidarité
appelle la franchise un événement est
passée relativement inaperçue la
victoire dans une ville bourgeoise et
industriels de stuttgart capitale d'un
land allemand d'un maire écologiste
personne ne s'est interrogé sur ce qui a
conduit à cette ville à élire un maire
écologiste
je voudrais relaté quelque chose de très
simple le transfert d'une gare existante
ultra moderne a fait l'objet d'une
polémique dans la ville des personnes du
troisième âge n'ayant jamais manifesté
dès des personnes ayant pris
connaissance de ce dossier s'y sont
opposés pour trois raisons
première raison les lois sur l'eau était
bafouée et ne rentrait pas en ligne de
compte de ce qu'exige le lan allemand
deuxièmement les lois sur la
biodiversité et le respect de la
biodiversité n'ont pas été respectées
troisièmement la législation concernant
la consultation des usagers n'avait pas
été mené à son terme
pour dire les choses autrement
pour dire les choses autrement nous
avons depuis un certain temps et c'est
acté public un léger désaccord de fond
sur ce dossier n'ajoutons pas à ce
désaccord de fond qui est d'un point de
vue différent des problèmes de forme et
ma question est assez simple elle est la
suivante pourquoi autant de
précipitations et de vie relance alors
que tous les recours juridiques n'ont
pas été à leur terme
ni les recours juridiques au plan
national ni les recours juridiques au
plan international et pourquoi mettre en
place ces expulsions qui forcément vont
avoir un coût qui va se rajouter au
coude du projet nous ne sommes plus à
l'ère de l'essence peu cher nous ne
sommes plus à l'heure du kérosène peu
cher ce projet avait ses défenseurs il
ya quelques années parmi nous
écologistes il ya de très nombreux
adversaires de ce projet et ce projet ne
correspond plus à la réalité
d'aujourd'hui donc ma question est très
simple
pourquoi autant de virulence je ne parle
pas du coût des expulsions nous a parlé
de 500 millions d'euros je ne sais pas
si c'est vrai pourquoi autant de
précipitations sur un dossier qui n'est
pas complètement tranché et là je
voudrais très solennellement vous
appelez que à regarder que notre dame
des landes ne doit pas demain être des
ces nouveaux aéroports espagnols qui
sont des aéroports désertiques ou
personnes circulent ou personnes
voyagent regarde
regardez mes chers collègues ce qui se
passe à berlin l'aéroport billy brown
n'est toujours pas inaugurer alors que
là bas il n'y avait pas eu de problème
et consensus merci de votre réponse
merci monsieur frédéric cuvillier
ministre chargé des transports de la mer
et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice le projet
d'infrastructure auquel vous faites
référence l'infrastructure aérienne
notre dame des landes est un projet qui
somme toute ancien puisque engagé sous
la maîtrise d'ouvragé de l'état et
c'était en date de 2008
il est financé
mais portée de longue date par de
nombreuses collectivités c'est le cas
des régions départements des
intercommunalités
il s'agit non pas d'un nouvel aéroport
mais il s'agit d'un transfert de
l'aéroport nantes atlantique et ce pour
des raisons qui sont aussi des raisons
environnementales qu'il convient de
rappeler notamment la proximité de
l'aéroport nantes atlantique proximité
du centre ville et donc les conflits
d'usagé les nuisances sonores la qualité
de l'air également qui est prise en
compte un certain nombre de financements
ont été mobilisés c'est un projet qui
est aujourd'hui nos pas au début de sa
réalisation mais qui est en phase de
réalisation puisque la déclaration
d'utilité publique purgé de tout recours
juridique est maintenant applicable est
opposable et il appartient désormais aux
juridictions concernées de statuer sur
les derniers contentieux qui sont des
contentieux concernant la propriété et
l'expropriation
d'ailleurs dans la grande sagesse des
acteurs de ce projet il a été entendu
d'attendre le recours en cassation
les décisions que tant qu'ils ont été
prises concernant les transferts de
propriété donc l'état et les élus de
notre métropole du conseil régional ont
souhaité faire avancer ce dossier dans
le respect à la fois des intérêts de la
population des agriculteurs des
communautés de communes concernées et de
faire en sorte que cette méthode puisse
est une méthode à la fois de
concertation mais aussi de respect et
c'est dans ce sens que le gouvernement
soutient les procédures engagées au fait
référence aux enquêtes elles sont
nombreuses au procédure juridique
opposable
elles sont nombreuses et notamment c'est
le cas pour les procédures d'enquêté
publique en cours au titre de loi sur
l'eau vous le savez les infrastructures
et notamment des infrastructures de
cette importance peuvent avoir des
impacts sur l'eau sur les milieux
aquatiques et aquatiques et conformément
aux dispositions du code de
l'environnement madame la sénatrice des
dispositions spécifiques d'autorisation
de déclarations doivent être requises et
ces projets sont soumises à autorisation
comme c'est le cas du projet de
l'aéroport doit faire l'objet d'un
arrêté préfectoral d'autorisation est
par ailleurs
il doit être nécessaires pour le
pétitionnaire de délivrer un dossier
complet comportant étude d'impact
mesures compensatoires et mesures de
préservation des écosystèmes aquatiques
voilà l'ensemble de ce dispositif il n'y
a pas de précipitation il n'y a pas de
volonté d'un doute repasser des
procédures il y a à la fois un délai un
timing qui est respectée des procédures
qui sont sous contrôle des autorités
juridictionnelles et une fois encore les
enjeux qui sont des enjeux d'aménagement
du territoire des enjeux économiques et
bien évidemment le fait de les faire
rimer avec le respect des intérêts de
chacun est au coeur de la préoccupation
de la procédure telle qu'elle est depuis
2008 engagées par l'état au nom de
l'état et en collaboration avec les
collectivités locales
si la parole est à présent à monsieur
guy fischer pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des affaires sociales et de la santé
le dimanche 21 octobre dernier
monsieur le président de la république
françois hollande clôturait le congrès
de la mutualité française en ces termes
aucun français ne doit se trouver à plus
de 30 minutes de soins d'urgence aucun
instrument financier si ingénieux soit
il ne saurait remplacer une stratégie
humaine j'y étais et j'ai applaudi ces
fermes propos mais mais mais mais force
est de constater pourtant que les dégâts
infligés à notre système de soins par le
gouvernement précédent
il ya des véritables plans de sociaux
des restructurations et fermetures
d'établissements diligentée par les ars
sont considérables elles ne pourront
être réparées que par une politique
volontariste engager en urgence pour
mettre fin aux déserts médicaux
je concentrerai mon exemple sur les
maternités de proximité
nous assistons à une véritable fracture
sanitaire
suite à la fermeture des deux tiers de
nos maternités dans les trente dernières
années le temps de 45 minutes retenu
comme délai de référence en terme de
sécurité pour la mère et l'enfant n'est
plus respecté un cycle souligne la
coordination nationale des comités de
défense des hôpitaux et maternités de
proximité
le ufc que choisir de mon département
vient son tour de m'alerter en faisant
le lien entre déserts médicaux et
dépassements d'honoraires
cette association de consommateurs
souligne qu'au-delà des déserts
géographique zones rurales et quartiers
populaires des grands ensembles la
pénurie de médecins ne pratiquant pas de
dépassements d'honoraires accroît de
façon dramatique
l'inégalité dans l'accès aux soins dans
le rhône
le pourcentage de la population vivant
dans un désert médical gynécologique
passe de 9 à 99 % si l'on ne peut
financièrement accéder qu'à un
gynécologue au tarif sans dépassement
d'honoraires
ainsi se conjuguent de façon dramatique
fermetures de maternités et fracture
entre les patientes
face à une telle peu une aiguille il
faut agir agir vite et sur deux leviers
décrété un arrêt immédiat des fermetures
de maternités plafonner les dépassements
d'honoraires en gynécologie comme dans
d'autres secteurs en grande tension
je vous remercie de bien vouloir nous
faire connaître la position du
gouvernement
c'est leur cette urgence sanitaire merci
merci mon cher collègue pour vous
répandre la parole et à madame dominique
bertinotti ministre chargée de la
famille monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je vous prie tout d'abord
d'excusés
l'absence de marisol touraine qui est
retenu à l'assemblée nationale dans le
cadre du débat sur le plfss
vous dites monsieur le sénateur à quel
point le précédent gouvernement a abîmé
notre système de soins et vous avez
raison
si il est utile de rappeler la
multiplication des déremboursements de
médicaments
l'augmentation continue du forfait
hospitalier la création du forfait sur
les consultations médicales
les nouvelles taxes sur les mutuelles
l'explosion du niveau des dépassements
d'honoraires
effectivement les assurés ont eu
l'impression que leur couverture maladie
se rétrécissait comme peau de chagrin
alors c'est vrai s'impose une
réorganisation la réorganisation de
notre système pour permettre à tous
l'accès aux soins
cette réorganisation que conduit marisol
touraine consistera d'une part à
revaloriser les missions de l'hôpital
public et d'autre part à veiller à une
meilleure organisation de la médecine de
proximité car il est temps de bâtir de
bâtir les parcours hotu autour pardon du
patient et non plus autour des
structures pour permettre à chaque
français de se soigner près de chez lui
est engagé un combat contre les déserts
médicaux que vous soulignez cela se
traduit très concrètement par la
création dès 2013 de 200 postes d'eu
part à titien locaux de médecine
générale
car effectivement vous avez raison de le
souligner accéder un médecin est parfois
devenu un privilège cela doit redevenir
un droit il nous faudra évidemment aller
plus loin sur ce sujet en permettant à
chaque français d'accéder et vous avez
rappelé les propos de président de la
république en moins de 30 minutes à des
soins d'urgence en mettant en oeuvre
aussi des mécanismes d'incitation et
d'attractivité pour que les
professionnels viennent s'installer dans
les territoires sous dotées pour
faciliter la consultation d'un médecin
de ville
l'organisation en équipe permettra
d'accroître les horaires d'ouverture de
prendre en charge les demandes de soins
dans des délais raisonnables et d'éviter
ainsi tout passages inutiles aux
urgences en plus de la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux
il faut à terme diminuer le reste à
charge supportée par les familles les
français ne doivent plus renoncer à se
soigner pour des raisons financières
les françaises ne doivent pas mettre en
danger leur santé leur grossesse pour
des raisons financières
la négociation sur les dépassements
d'honoraires qui s'est achevé cette
semaine ont abouti sur un accord positif
et la gynécologie est aussi concerné par
cet accord les françaises en
bénéficieront vous le voyez monsieur le
sénateur l'action du gouvernement est
résolu action contre les déserts
médicaux d'un côté accord pour diminuer
progressivement le reste à charge des
familles c'est ainsi que nous nous
dirigeons vers le respect de l'égalité
de l'accès aux soins pour tous
merci la parole et à monsieur bruno sido
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
alors mesdames monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre je
souhaiterais évoqué mais madame la
branche répondre à ma question donc
j'évoquerai la situation financière très
difficile des départements situation qui
provient de l'inadéquation des dépenses
des allocations de solidarité et de leur
financement
le panier des allocations ne cesse de
s'alourdir dans le fonctionnement des
départements
en 2012 il devrait croître de 4,4 pour
cent alors même que les ressources
destinées à les compenser sont en hausse
de 0,6 pour cent en 2004 l'état couvrait
70% des allocations de solidarité en
2010 il n'en garantit c'est plus que 59%
les sang or un reste à charge au
département de 5,8 milliards d'euros
2013 risque d'être plus difficile encore
si la reconnaissance des départements et
de leur difficulté n'est plus à
démontrer en atteste l'audience
que le président de la république et je
l'en remercie d'ailleurs et son premier
ministre ont accordé avec ses ministres
lundi dernier c'est exact c'est exact
ces dernières une délégation de
présidents de conseils généraux nous
attendons aujourd'hui des actes forts et
concrets
au terme de ces échanges qui ont eu lieu
lundi donc à l'elysée il a été fait
mention de la mise en oeuvre des
conditions pérenne de financement des
dépenses de solidarité je rappelle l'ap
hm le rsa la pch
mais rien ne serait mise en place avant
aujourd'hui comme hier les départements
sont conscients de la situation des
comptes publics de la nation mais
j'affirme que répondre à la question du
financement des trois allocations
individuelles de solidarité est un
préalable pour restaurer la confiance
entre l'état et les conseils généraux
d'ailleurs quand je dis j'affirme les
102 présidents de conseil général la
firme la réforme annoncée se fait chaque
jour de plus en plus pressante pour les
départements nous attendons des
engagements forts qui nous permettront
de sortir des impasses financières dans
lesquelles certains d'entre nous se
trouve d'ores et déjà et dans laquelle
se trouveront tous demain alors avant de
trouver la solution financière qui est
appelé par les votes tout le monde il
est attendu dans un premier temps par
les départements un véritable coup de
pouce pour compenser certaines dépenses
il est évoqué une aide exceptionnelle de
170 millions françois fillon avait mis
140 millions il ya deux ans destiné une
trentaine de départements
structurellement fragiles et qui rennes
qui n'avait pas assuré à assumer leur
mission
mais qui sont ils ces départements quels
critères seront ils de désigner quand on
sait que c'est la majorité des
départements qui est en difficulté dans
un deuxième temps les départements
attendent une montée en puissance
je vous suggérerais de réserver une
issue favorable à la ppl de notre
collègue gérard roche
elle propose l'élargissement de la
première journée de solidarité à
l'ensemble des actifs
en particulier les retraités elle ne
rapporterait pas moins de 900 millions
d'euros au département
il en serait de même pour la ppl du
sénateur béchu relatives aux allocations
familiales et à l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire pour les enfants placés à lyon
vous avez largement dépassé le temps il
faut arriver c'est en attendant monsieur
le premier département attendent une
meilleure prise en compte des
difficultés immédiates qui touche les
finances des départements je vous
remercie pour votre réponse
merci chers collègues la parole est à
mme adam et marylise lebranchu ministre
de la réforme de l'état de la
décentralisation de la fonction publique
merci monsieur le président du sénat
mesdames et messieurs des sénatrices et
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur puisque nous sommes
dans une ambiance absolument sereine et
apaisée que vous êtes salué l'initiative
du président de la république quand je
vous entends me dire quand nous dire
pardonnez-moi qu'en 2004 la situation
était déjà dur pour les départements
nous sommes en 2012 j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya une dizaine d'années que la
relation entre les départements et
l'étain est un petit peu une relation
amateuriste parce qu'il ya longtemps
monsieur le président du conseil général
qu'on aurait pu se rendre compte que
passer de 50 pour cent cinquante 50 de
financement de l'apa à 70,30 allait
forcément générer cet effet de ciseaux
que le président de la république qui
connaît bien les départements a bien
voulu discuter échanger des conséquences
avec l'ensemble des présidents de
conseils généraux
vous dites ça n'a pas été assez concret
effectivement 10 en six mois
vous avez six mois que nous vous avons
pris ce dossier avec anne marie
escoffier à bras le corps et que nous
cherchons qu'elle avec le ministre de
l'économie et des finances et le
ministre du budget qu'elle est
effectivement la bonne solution de
financement pour les départements de la
même manière que nous cherchons la bonne
solution de financement pour les
conseils régionaux je vois le premier
ministre raffarin qui le rappelait dans
un colloque récent
bien ses conseils régionaux qui n'ont
plus du tout de manne fiscale de
dynamique fiscale donc nous nous
engageons à quoi monsieur le président
d'abord à ce que dans la loi qui va
venir sur les compétences
rien ne souhaite transférer
décentralisée ou délégués sans que nous
ayons discuter en même temps de la
ressource que rien ne soit donnée entre
guillemets au département qui puisse
aggraver la situation mais nous avons
pris l'engagement et c'est le président
de la république il est dit l'autre jour
de mettre 170 millions d'euros à
disposition des départements pour que
ceux ci puissent répondre d'une part à
cet effet de ciseaux dont je parlais
mais aussi aux engagements qu'ils
viennent de prendre et que nous saluons
toutes tendances politiques confondues
nos départements s'engage sur les
emplois d'avenir 7000 nous département
s'engage sur les contrats aidés
nos départements s'engage sur le service
civique de départements ont accepté de
s'engager dans l'urgence sur le logement
social il faut saluer l'exemple qu'a pu
nous donner le président du conseil
général de la drôme
à ce sujet nous département acceptent de
s'engager pour que l'investissement
public réponde aux besoins de nos
habitants de nos citoyens et que cet
investissement public aussi soit
générateur de croissance et c'est
pourquoi monsieur le président nous
avons aussi décidé ne ne pas diminuer
l'aide aux collectivités territoriales
cette année et j'en termine puisque j'ai
dépassé le temps le ministre du budget
s'engage avec nous pour qu'au collectif
2012 on ait trouvé des critères à partir
d autofinancement nos financements ned
pardon pour répondre à votre juste
inquiétude celle suivent d'audignies
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres
chaque legs ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre chargée des personnes
âgées et de l'autonomie madame la
ministre
la question concerne les services d'
aide à domicile nul
d'entre nous n'ignore les difficultés
financières majeures auxquelles sont
confrontées les associations de services
d aide à domicile pour les personnes
âgées et les personnes handicapées non
plus que la gravité des conséquences
sociales et économiques de ces
difficultés pour nos territoires
le secteur des services à domicile est
essentiel il l'est pour le vivre
ensemble
il est pour la masse et la manne
d'emplois solidaires n'ont décollé non
délocalisables qu'il représente
fin 2009 faute de réaction du
gouvernement de l'époque
l'assemblée des départements de france a
pris l'initiative concrétiser d'abord en
2010 par l'adoption avec seize
fédérations et à l'unanimité d'un projet
de refondation de l'aide à domicile
prestataires autorisés par les conseils
généraux puis en 2011 par la signature
d'une plateforme commune entre l'adf et
14 fédérations rejointes ensuite par une
15e l'une des six propositions phares de
cette plateforme porté sur un nouveau
mode de tarification horaire
cette proposition a été reprise pour
expérimentation par la loi de finances
pour 2012
mais l'arrêté d'encadrement qui devait
être publié en février 2012 par le
précédent gouvernement a été bloqué pour
des raison inexpliquée et inexplicable
nous nous sommes donc féliciter madame
la ministre que vous ayez très
rapidement décidé la publication de cet
arrêté journal officiel du 21 septembre
des expérimentations à cet égard était
certes déjà lancé mais beaucoup de
départements restait dans l'attenté de
cette publication dont les trois annexes
fixed à cahier des charges qui sécurise
les expérimentations et permettra d'en
assurer le suivi et l'évaluation
ainsi le département de l'aisne pour
n'en citer qu'un vient t-il à la suite
de cet arrêté de contractualiser avec
les associations pour expérimenter à
tarif au forfait global mais cela n'est
pas tout d'autres mesures
immédiate et de plus long terme sont
également nécessaires
pouvez vous madame la ministre éclairer
la représentation nationale sur vos
projets contenu je les vis de
l'importance majeure du secteur pour la
vitalité de nos territoires et de
l'emploi je vous remercie
merci madame michèle delaunay ministres
changent et des personnes âgées de
l'autonomie monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs monsieur le sénateur
nos dîners je ne peux que souscrire à
chacune de vos paroles le secteur le
secteur de l'aide à domicile qui
représentent plus de 8000 structure et
plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'emplois fait face aujourd'hui à de
lourdes difficultés et il doit bien
souvent compter sur l'appui des
départements pour y faire face l'aide à
domicile sous forme associative a ainsi
perdu 5% de ses effectifs et au cours de
l'année 2010 et 2012 et 2011 sont 16 mai
d'emplois qui ont été touchés pour cette
raison j'ai déposé des l'actuel projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale un amendement visant à consacrer
au secteur un fonds de restructuration
de 50 millions d'euros qui permettra de
sauver plusieurs milliers d'emplois en
contrepartie vous le savez des
associations devront évoluer vers plus
de regroupement plus de mutualisation
plus de professionnalisation et
s'engager de manière plus ferme encore
dans une politique de prévention
préparant ainsi le volet prévention de
la future réforme de la perte
d'autonomie que le président de la
république et le premier ministre ont
annoncé ainsi que sur le plan métier que
nous envisageons pour ce secteur dont le
potentiel et vous le savez
de 300000 emplois à l'horizon 2020 vous
l'avez rappelé il s'agit de plus
d'emplois non délocalisables
initialement peu qualifiés et vecteur
d'inclusion sociale pour nombre de ceux
qui s'y engagent
par ailleurs pour sécuriser les
expérimentations menées par les conseils
généraux en matière de tarification
qu'elle repose sur le modèle porté par
l'assemblée des départements et la
fédération des 15 ou sur celui proposé
par le rapport de madame politi j'aidais
mon arrivée demandé que l'arrêté fixant
les le cahier des charges de ces
expérimentations soit enfin publié cette
publication le 27 ans montre notre
engagement mon engagement aux côtés des
départements pour poursuivre ou initiés
ces expérimentations le domicile est au
coeur de notre politique de l'âge et
ceci conformément au souhait des
français de demeurer chez eux le plus
longtemps possible tout en restant
pleinement acteurs de la société en
partenariat avec les départements
nous sommes d'ores et déjà engagé dans
la large issement de l'offre de domicile
parallèlement l'engagement vous a été
donné à l'elysée par le président de la
république lui même de mieux prendre en
compte les difficultés des du
département et cette démarche nous la
ferons en partenariat étroit avec vous
tous mais la parlotte à monsieur antoine
le soz oeuvre pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture monsieur le
ministre
alors que se tient cette semaine à paris
comme tous les deux ans le salon
international de l'alimentation
force est de constater que le made in
france cher au ministre du redressement
productif est aussi dans nos assiettes
l'agroalimentaire est un atout important
pour notre commerce extérieur
tout comme l'était notre agriculture
jeudi était car en effet celle ci a été
devancé ces dernières années par nos
voisines allemandes et néerlandaises
notre agriculture a donc besoin d'un
soutien ferme de nos gouvernants et non
pas de revirements successifs qui met à
mal les prévisions de nos agriculteurs
en effet tout récemment et au nom de la
protection de la biodiversité
vous avez monsieur le ministre avec
votre collègue de l'écologie informée la
profession de votre volonté de porter de
3 à 4% sur les exploitations
les surfaces qui doivent être occupés
par des jachères plantations pièce d'eau
etc
c'est ce qu'on appelle les haies se tait
surface en équivalent topographiques
à l'origine ces éléments devraient
devait représenter 1% dans le dossier
pac puis 3% en 2011
gelé en 2012 alors que la campagne 2012
2013 est déjà engagé avec des programmes
d'assolement déjà défini et des semences
qui sont déjà commencé un tel changement
de règle va générer un manque à gagner
certain pour les agriculteurs sans
aucune contrepartie alors que les
discussions pour la pac 2014 sont
sensibles en ce qui concerne son
verdissement
une telle initiative tendant à réduire
encore et sans préalable les surfaces
cultivables
c'est un signal prématurée en devançant
une décision qui n'est pas encore prise
la france se retrouve donc comme souvent
en distorsion de concurrence avec ses
voisins d'autant que la décision
européenne n'est pas arrêté il semble
d'ailleurs que vous auriez évoqué votre
soutien à une hausse jusqu'à 7% dans le
cadre de la future pac
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs sont bien
conscients des enjeux liés à
l'environnement et à la biodiversité
mais ces initiatives ne doivent pas
entraver la compétitivité de notre
agriculture
je vous remercie donc monsieur le
ministre de bien vouloir considérer les
appels des agriculteurs qui vous
demandent de
renoncer à ce projet d'accroissement des
cds se tait pardon qui va contribuer
attendre encore plus le marché
alimentaire
merci merci monsieur guillaume garot
ministre chargé de l'agroalimentaire
merci monsieur le sénateur je veux
d'abord présenté les excuses de stéphane
le foll qui est retenu au congrès de
l'association nationale des élus de la
montagne anem et qui n'a pu être parmi
nous aujourd'hui
alors monsieur le sénateur
la france doit préparer l'avenir et elle
doit le faire s'agissant de son
agriculture
en répondant à la fois aux enjeux
économiques mais aussi aux enjeux
environnementaux pour conquérir une
nouvelle compétitivité alors que vous ne
l'ignorez pas monsieur le sénateur nous
avons perdu tant de terrain depuis dix
ans alors après concertation avec
l'ensemble des syndicats agricoles et
avec l'ensemble des ong
environnementales et en plein accord
avec la ministre de l'écologie delphine
batho stéphane le foll en effet notre
ministre de l'agriculture a décidé fin
septembre de faire passer le seuil des
esters de 3 à 4% pour l'année 2013 alors
pourquoi
pour une raison simple parce que nous
sommes convaincus que l'agriculture doit
inventer un nouveau modèle faisant de
l'engagement environnemental un atout
pour nos agriculteurs et donc d'où
soutenons nous soutiendrons les
agriculteurs pour relever ce défi
environnemental c'est bien le sens de
cette décision et je rappelle que dans
le cadre des négociations de la réforme
de la pac
la commission européenne propose que
chaque exploitation respecte un
pourcentage de 7% des surfaces d'intérêt
écologique et vous savez
que la france soutient cet objectif
européen de parvenir à 7% et donc nous
défendons l'idée d'inclure non seulement
des éléments topographiques comme l'est
mais aussi des cultures qui sont
intéressantes d'un point de vue
environnemental ça concerne le lin ça
concerne le chambre ça concerne
également les légumineuses
je parlais du chambre j'ai parlé du
champ droit
je vois que ça vous fait sourire
il n'y a pas matière à sourire il s'agit
bien d'agriculture en tout cas même son
ministre photo mais en tout cas c'est en
travaillant plus sérieusement merci de
votre attention mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
c'est en travaillant de façon
progressive est toujours déterminée dans
ce sens que nous pourrons engager le
changement pour une agriculture
économiquement et écologiquement
performante je suis sûr monsieur le
sénateur que nous obtiendrons un large
accord de votre assemblée sur ce projet
sur cette ambition pour tout simplement
réussir la mutation dont notre
agriculture a besoin je vous remercie
merci d'apple est un monsieur roland
ries ce pour le groupe socialiste
voilà le président mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues je
souhaite interpeller le gouvernement sur
un sujet qui concerne strasbourg mais
qui concerne aussi globalement la france
je parlais de la présence du parlement
européen dans la ville dont je suis le
maire comme vous le savez cette présence
est depuis longtemps contesté par un
certain nombre de députés européens et
par des lobbys de toutes sortes qui
souhaitent comme ils disent
un siège unique one seat en franglais du
parlement à bruxelles
cette bataille a pris depuis quelques
jours un tour nouveau avec une offensive
d'une grande violence contre strasbourg
et donc indirectement contre la france
ce positionnement est en contradiction
totale précise avec l'esprit et la
lettre des traités fondateurs de l'union
européenne qui non seulement fixe le
siège du parlement européen à strasbourg
mais de plus met en avant l' année le
nécessaire polycentrisme européen et la
répartition des sièges des institutions
européennes dans plusieurs villes à
travers l'europe et pas seulement
d'ailleurs à strasbourg à luxembourg et
à bruxelles des votes importante encore
eu lieu avant-hier 23 octobre 2012
sur la question du siège ils font suite
à la série de votes auxquels nous
assistons depuis le vote de l'amendement
fox qui prévoit l'organisation dans la
même semaine de deux sessions
parlementaires de deux jours chacune
pour contourner les traités qui stipule
que 12 session annuelle du parlement
européen doivent se tenir à strasbourg 7
évidemment inacceptable et cette ruse
je devrais dire cette manipulation ne
peut que jeter le discrédit sur les
travaux du parlement européen tout
entier
je vous demande donc le seul ministre de
réaffirmer solennellement l'attachement
la france à la présence du parlement
européen sur son territoire à strasbourg
le réaffirmer que ce point n'est pas
négociable
ou alors qu'il faut rouvrir la
négociation sur l'ensemble des sièges de
nos institutions européennes c'est à
dire en réalité ouvrir la boîte de
pandore ce dont personne ne veut et
enfin de redire que six sièges unique
il doit y avoir ce siège ne peut être
qu'à strasbourg conformément à l'esprit
et à la lettre des traités
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre de
nous aider à faire face à ces nouvelles
offensives dans lesquelles la mauvaise
foi se conjugue à une agressivité
grandissante est proprement inacceptable
j'ajoute que c'est aussi une certaine
conception la construction européenne
qui se profile à l'arrière-plan de ce
débat à léran à l'europe économique et
normatives telle qu'elle se construit à
bruxelles à l'europe judiciaire et
financière telle qu'elle se construit à
luxembourg et à francfort
il est plus que jamais nécessaire
d'adjoindre l'europe des peuples et des
droits de l'homme telle qu'elle
s'élabore depuis longtemps à strasbourg
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
vos réponses il est de votre sous sol
est ce dossier monsieur vide à nice
alain vidalis ni chargé des relations
avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur joue donc bien vouloir excuser
l'absence de bernard cazeneuve qui est
actuellement en déplacement en bulgarie
vous connaissez l'attachement des
autorités françaises au rayonnement
européen de la ville de strasbourg et au
siège strasbourgeois du parlement
européen notre position est simple
la france est attachée au respect des
traités qui ont fixé le siège du
parlement européen à strasbourg
pour nous cette décision est intangible
et non négociable la localisation des
institutions européennes et notamment du
parlement européen dans plusieurs villes
permet de préserver cette europe
polycentrique à laquelle nous tenons car
elle constitue un outil précieux pour
lutter contre la perception au sein des
opinions publiques d'institutions
lointaine opaque et déconnectée des
préoccupations des citoyens
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes très vigilants au respect des
traités
c'est dans cet esprit que nous avons
saisi la cour de justice de l'union
européenne
contre la délibération du parlement
européen relatives au calendrier des
sessions 2012 et 2013 qui tendent à
réduire le nombre de sessions plénières
à strasbourg les conclusions rendues le
6 septembre 2012 par l'avocat général de
la cour de justice dans cette affaire
vont dans le sens de la position
défendue par les autorités françaises
l'avocat général estime en effet que les
sessions plénières d'octobre 2012 et
2013 artificiellement scindée en deux
par le parlement européen ne peuvent
être qualifiés individuellement de
sessions plénières mensuelles et propose
à la cour d'annuler les délibérations du
parlement européen relatives au
calendrier des périodes de sessions
parlementaires pour 2012 et 2013
les autorités françaises ont pris note
des conclusions dès leur publication
il appartient maintenant à la cour de
rendre son arrêt cela devrait être fait
d'ici la fin de l'année si l'on se fonde
sur les délais usuels
cette saisine de la cour de justice est
une illustration de plus de notre
détermination sur le sujet que vous
évoquez le siège strasbourgeois du
parlement européen pour nous n'est pas
négociable
telle est la position du gouvernement
monsieur le sénateur-maire type monsieur
philippe adnot pour la réunion
administrative et sénateurs de figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe
je veux remercier monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre délégué chargé des transports
de la mer et de la pêche l'état s'est
engagé dans la voie difficile de la
maîtrise budgétaire et a demandé que
l'effort soit aussi partagées par les
différentes collectivités locales on
peut le comprendre et pour ma part j'y
souscris tout en faisant observer le
fait que les départements sont dans une
situation particulière dans la mesure où
une bonne part des dépenses sociales
qu'ils assument sont des dépenses
obligatoires sur lesquels ils n'ont pas
de prise
si les collectivités locales sont
appelées à contribuer à l'effort
il me paraîtrait normal que l'état joue
franc jeu et fasse tout son possible de
son côté pour ne pas augmenter
les dépenses obligatoires je voudrais
illustrer ce principe en citant
l'exemple de l'obligation qui est faite
en matière de transport scolaire pour
d'une part aux transporteurs d'aminé
d'aménager les quarts en vue du
transport des personnes handicapées et
d'autre part aux communes d'aménager en
conséquence tous les arrêts de car
l'exécution de cette obligation
représente dans mon département près de
1000 points d'arrêt à la charge des
communes est une dépense annuelle
supplémentaire de 900 mille euros pour
le conseil général
résultant de la diminution du nombre de
places dans chacun des quarts et du
surcoût contractuels facturés par les
transporteurs
cette dépense de 900000 euros est à
mettre au regard avec les 800000 euros
déjà consacré par le conseil général au
transport des handicapés puisque cela
est tout à fait légitime nous sommes
tenus d'aller chercher ces personnes à
leur domicile soit parce que le ne
peuvent pas se rendre aux points d'arrêt
soit parce que le lieu d'enseignement ne
correspond pas à ceux desservis par les
circuits classiques et donc qu'aucune
d'elles qu'aucune d'entre elles
finalement n'utilise et donc nous voyons
tous que cela va créer une double
dépense ma question est la suivante
monsieur le ministre
dans le contexte de maîtrise budgétaire
êtes vous prêt à reporter de cinq ans le
terme de cette obligation de mise en
conformité telles qu'évoquées par la
circulaire du 3 mai 2007 afin d'éviter
aux communes et aux départements de
supporter des dépenses supplémentaires
au moment précis où vous diminuez les
concours que vous leur apportez merci ne
parlaient à monsieur le ministre
frédéric cuvillier merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
sénateurs permettez moi tout d'abord
d'excuser l'absence de marie arlette
carlotti qui est en charge de la
question du handicap au sein de ce
gouvernement
mais puisqu'il s'agit d'une question
relative à l'accessibilité dans le
domaine des transports
c'est une question que nous portons
collectivement de votre question est
importante en effet puisqu'il s'agit de
difficultés dans l'application de la loi
que rencontre
nombre de collectivités puisque la loi
du 11 février 2005 en effet portant sur
l'égalité des droits et des chances la
participation et la citoyenneté des
personnes handicapées dispose que les
services de transport collectif devront
être accessibles aux personnes
handicapées et la mobilité réduite au
plus tard le 12 février 2015
c'est un objectif qui est essentiel
c'est un objectif qui est indispensable
indiscutable même cela fait maintenant
un certain nombre d'années que le
principe en a été posée je tiens
d'ailleurs à cette occasion signalé a
souligné le travail considérable qui a
été conquis a été réalisée par les
différentes collectivités pour se mettre
à niveau afin d'adapter l'accessibilité
des transports ce soit les bus les
voiries les gars bref d'innombrables
travaux qui ont un coût effectivement et
mais force est de constater que aussi
trop nombreuses sur les collectivités
qui n'ont pas encore ne serait-ce qu
adopté le schéma directeur
d'accessibilité et que c'est un travail
de diagnostic indispensable préalable
permettant de programmer dans le temps
les dépenses nécessaires pour pouvoir
parvenir à ce niveau au niveau
d'accessibilité et éventuellement de
détecter les difficultés et pouvoir
avancer sur ce sujet le cool ces
investissements est réel et important
mais il existe une dynamique qu'il
convient de souligner et d'encourager et
élu local et monsieur sénateurs je ne
méconnais pas les difficultés auxquelles
sont confrontés les collectivités dans
ce domaine le gouvernement en est
pleinement conscient et d'ailleurs jean
marc ayrault a confié à une de vos
collègues madame la sénatrice claire
lise campion une mission visant à
définir avec les acteurs de terrain les
moyens à mettre en oeuvre pour atteindre
les gens qui les objectifs en 2015
je souligne simplement que cette
question n'est pas n'est pas inconnu à
la fois du gouvernement honni du
président de la république vous avez eu
l'occasion d'ailleurs il ya quelques
jours doit faire état au président de la
république avec ma collègue marie
arlette
carlotti lors d'une réunion avec
l'ensemble des présidents du conseil des
conseils généraux est important qu'il y
ait concertation
il est important aussi qu'il y ait
exigences j'étais à la fédération
nationale des transports de voyageurs et
j'apprenais à cette occasion que ce 15 %
de la flotte est peut-être aujourd'hui
mise au niveau d'accessibilité pour les
personnes handicapées c'est insuffisant
on me disait même je fais le fait
vérifier parmi les services de mon
ministère qu'il existait encore des
appels d'offres pour du matériel roulant
qui n'étaient pas aux normes
d'adaptabilité et d'accès pour les
personnes handicapées ce qu'il faut
vérifier et je m'engage à pouvoir raf a
de pouvoir faire en sorte que
l'information soit donnée et si même
votre collègue catherine procaccia lors
d'une précédente question ne rencontrent
à l'occasion des questions orales avait
souligné combien il était important
aussi de faire oeuvre d'information
notamment pour que à la fois notamment
dans le domaine des transports les taxis
acceptent la présence de chiens
accompagnant les aveugles bref il y as
au delà des obligations qu'elle soit
matérielle ou financière aussi un
comportement à l'égard des personnes
handicapées et ce comportement est
indispensable pour pouvoir mieux vivre
ensemble
merci mes chers collègues je vais
suspens suspendre la séance reprendra à
16h15 pour l'examen de la proposition de
loi tendant à élargir la contribution de
solidarité pourront se retrouver
ensemble la science avec nos invités à
tout de suite en